Arduino an open source programmable
circuit board and microcontroller that
makes it possible for anyone to build
digital Hardware products the idea
started in Italy in 2005 and today has
sold over 10 million boards worldwide
the most popular model is the Uno and at
its heart we have a microcontroller
which is like a small inexpensive
computer that can run on low power the
board is surrounded by pins that can be
used to construct a circuit by
connecting various input and output
devices most importantly though it has a
USB port that's used to easily upload
your code to the device in Arduino a
software program is called a sketch
which is written in a purpose-built easy
to learn programming language every
program has two basic functions setup
runs once when the hardware is first
powered on and loop runs continuously to
react to signals from input devices or
changes to the state of the program
arduinos have been used to build iot
products robots wearable devices and all
kinds of other crazy Hardware ideas to
get started obtain a board then download
its custom IDE or use the vs code plugin
if you prefer once installed connect
your board via USB then create a new
sketch which is just a file ending in
dot Ino the language itself feels like a
simplified version of C with plenty of
built-in functions to make Hardware
coding more accessible the setup
function runs once when the board is
reset or powered up we could use the
built-in pin mode function to select a
pin like the built-in LED and then
configure it as an input or output and
now in the loop function we can turn the
LED on by writing to it with a value of
high which is a constant that will
increase the voltage to that pin and
make it shine to make it blink we can
follow it with a delay then switch the
voltage to low and now we can hit the
upload button to compile and run this
code on the arduino's microcontroller
congratulations you just built a custom
Hardware product but there's a lot more
we could do here connect a breadboard to
it to create circuits without the need
for soldering the Arduino can power it
by connecting the positive side to the 5
volt pin and the negative side to the
ground pin and now connect components
like LEDs capacitors resistors battery
attacks Motors and switches to the
breadboard these components then connect
back to the digital pins on the Arduino
once connected these components can be
controlled in your code by referencing
the pin number with a little bit of code
you can make it do anything you can
imagine this has been Arduino in 100
seconds hit the like button if you want
to see more Hardware development content
on this channel thanks for watching and
I will see you in the next one